Die zwei Sprechstunden.
Ich bin ein Kumpel von Kumpel.
Ich bin ein Kumpel von Kumpel. Ich bin ein Kumpel von Kumpel. Ich bin ein Kumpel von Kumpel.
Aber braucht man sozusagen, wenn man Politik macht, auch ein dickes Fell?
Ach, natürlich. So wie Dutch jetzt beschrieben hat, ist es ja nicht der Normalfall. Ich finde das alles so toll, idealtypisch. Das hat auch so hingehauen. Das ist total toll.
Das tut mir leid, hätte ich da mehr Stress reinbringen sollen.
Ich bin da fast ein bisschen neidisch, weil natürlich viele von den politischen Projekten, die wir in den letzten Jahren so betreut haben, jetzt ich selbst, aber auch andere im Club, wo ich es live mitbekommen habe, die sind natürlich keineswegs so motivierend und so erfolgreich. Dann haben sie sich oft auch in der Bundespolitik dann manifestiert. Da ist es längst nicht so angenehm, überhaupt nicht so konstruktiv, sondern wesentlich festgefahrener, nicht so schön. Dort hat er eben beschrieben, wie im Justizausschuss in Hamburg, weil man den typischen Ausschuss im Bundestag sieht, also Justizausschuss oder Unterausschuss Neue Medien, da ist es keineswegs so konstruktiv. Und es ist auch oft so, wenn man eine Anhörung hat, dann fragt die Partei, die einen Experten einlädt, nur ihren Experten oder auch viele Parlamentarier, hören gar nicht zu, also beteiligen sich letztlich gar nicht an der Debatte, sondern klicken auf ihren iPhones oder auf ihren Computern rum. Und Prinzip geben oder geben nur die Parteimannung wieder. Also es ist nicht immer so schön angenehm wie in Hamburg. Oder aber auch, dass von vornherein klar ist, dass jeder Vorschlag, der nicht auf Linie ist, der Partei abgelehnt wird. Also so schön konstruktiv.
Also egal, was man sagt, wenn es nicht zur Farbe passt, dann ist es so.
Also die Rituale sind einfach stärker. Und dann diese elenden Geschäftsordnungstricks.
Aber lohnt es sich trotzdem, das zu machen? Club, ihr habt doch Experten. Komm mal bitte vor, denen du den Ausschuss hast. Hast du da ein Beispiel für?
Wir haben in jüngster Zeit das wieder gemacht. Wir hatten eine ganze Zeit lang überhaupt keine Stellungnahmen schriftlicher Art. Für gesetzgebende Ausschüsse mehr abgegeben, weil wir einfach für vergebene Zeit gehalten haben.
Kannst du noch mal kurz erläutern, wie sowas funktioniert? Also wo der Punkt ist, wo der Club dann gefragt wird. Schreib mal bitte was.
Ja, das ist unterschiedlich. Aber im Wesentlichen sieht der Prozess so aus. Dass es eine Idee für ein Gesetzgebungsverfahren gibt und irgendein gesetzgebender Ausschuss, der sich darum kümmert. Also in der Regel ist es eben etwas netzpolitikennahes. Oft eben Justiz oder innen. Und dann ist es so, dass jede Partei dort sich zu Anhörungen Experten einladen kann. Das ist aber meistens schon der mittlere Entstehungsprozess des Gesetzes. Das heißt, dass es meistens schon konkrete Vorschläge gibt. Manchmal auch nicht. Manchmal wird auch früher debattiert, aber in der Regel hat man schon irgendwas Schriftliches vorliegen. Dann bittet man die Experten um Stellungnahmen. Das ist meistens mit vorformulierten Fragen, die man dann beantworten kann, zum Teil oder vollständig. Dann gibt es eine mögliche Anhörung, die in der Regel 2-3 Stunden ist. Manchmal auch länger. Man gibt auch schriftlich die Stellungnahme ab. Dann gesellt man sich zu dem anderen Stapel Papier.
Ich würde gerade sagen, wird man dann auch instrumentalisiert? Also im Sinne von, wir haben ja die Leute vom Club jetzt gehört, sind ja alle Fachmeinungen vertreten?
Das ist halt auch ein Vorwurf, der uns wieder gemacht wurde, wo wir auch manchmal selbst den Eindruck hatten, dass es letztlich nichts bringt außer Arbeit und dass man da eigentlich gegen Wände redet. Deswegen haben wir das auch lange nicht mehr gemacht. In jüngster Zeit haben wir das wieder gemacht. Das hat auch mit dem Unterausschuss neue Medien zu tun. Der hat nämlich ein relativ offenes Konzept. Die Sitzung kann man verfolgen. Da gibt es einen Hashtag für Twitter. Das heißt, da ist mehr Debatte, da kommt schon mal eine Frage, die auf Twitter gestellt wurde, direkt in den Ausschuss. Das ist also offener und macht dadurch auch mehr Spaß, wenn man sich beteiligt, wenn man zumindest eine gewisse Resonanz hat. Und nicht so sehr diese festgefahrenen Rituale. Natürlich war er trotzdem irgendwie Siegfried Kauder von der CDU. Und hat da seinen Schuh, also die Rede, die er sowieso immer ablässt. Aber das ist dann eher erheiternd, weil man die Twitter-Kommentare wenigstens noch hat, die auch verstehen, wie inhaltlich sinnlos gerade war.
Ist das denn so, dass man dann quasi auch in kleinen Politik macht, indem man sich als Clubmitglied oder als Hacker dann nur an solchen Sachen beteiligt, wo man denkt, das hat auch irgendwie Erfolgs-Aussicht?
Na, das ist ja, na, Dodger hat eben so angedeutet, wie das so ist mit der ehrenamtlichen Arbeit und einfach auch der Zeit, die man reinsteckt. Ich meine, er selbst hatte jetzt wieder gerade gemerkt, wir im Club, wir haben natürlich für die verschiedenen Themen auch einfach nur eine begrenzte Manpower. Und ich glaube, da ist das Effizienzdenken in Bezug auf, wo stecken wir jetzt Zeit rein, ziemlich ausgeprägt. Wir überlegen uns schon, welche Kämpfe kann man vielleicht gewinnen, wo macht es Sinn oder wo redet man eigentlich gegen Wände und braucht das auch nicht tun. Und wenn man zum Beispiel eine Stellungnahme schreibt, das sollte man nicht unterschätzen. Wie viel Aufriss ist sowas? Na ja, in der Regel ist es auf jeden Fall immer eine Arbeit, die mehrere Leute zusammen machen. Da schreibt da irgendwie keiner alleine. Also wir benutzen da kollaborative Werkzeuge auch schon lange.
Und dann bevorzugt nachts, weil man ja noch einen Dayjob hat. Also ich kann mich an die letzte erinnern, da ging es um ein Landesparlament, wo eine der Parteien einen sehr lustigen Open-Data-Vorschlag eingebracht hatte, der eigentlich nur die Übersetzung der Webseite der Open Knowledge Foundation war und die Grundsätze auch noch falsch übersetzt hatten. Und da haben wir uns dann halt auch, also die Leute aus dem Bundesland im Club haben halt gesagt, du, die haben uns hier gefragt, ob wir da eine Stellungnahme abgeben können. Und das haben wir dann halt gelesen, haben gesagt, ja, okay, da muss man jetzt eine Stellungnahme abgeben. Und die haben das auch mit so einer schönen Frist gemacht von drei Tagen.
Ja, genau, man darf die Fristen nicht vergessen.
Weil die gehen ja davon aus, dass du irgendwie Vollzeitaktivist bist und an deinem Rechner sitzt und darauf wartest, dass irgendjemand sagt, so bitte schreib hier mal ein Pamphlet. Und dann sieht das halt so aus, dass dann vier Leute nachts in einem Bett arbeiten und dann morgens noch mal eine Stunde schlafen und dann wieder an die Arbeit gehen.
Es ist auch dann noch so, in der Regel möchte man ja flankieren mit der Informierung der Öffentlichkeit. Also jetzt der klubinternen Öffentlichkeit, aber auch der netzpolitischen Öffentlichkeit, aber auch allen Zeitungen. Also kommt ja immer noch der Medienaspekt dazu davor, dabei und danach. Natürlich stellen sich dann wieder Fragen. Und da ist immer noch ein bisschen mehr als das reine Schreiben. Und man muss natürlich auch jemanden, den man vorzeigen kann, dann da hinsetzen. Das macht ja auch nicht jeder Hacker. Man muss mal sehen, dass nicht alle Hacker bereit sind, sich da irgendwie mit einem Sacko hinzusetzen.
Also wer Politik macht, braucht keine anderen Hobbys.
Ach na, also, dort, wie sieht es mit dir aus? Ich habe schon noch andere Hobbys.
Na, ich war, lass mich überlegen, ich war Minigolfspieler.
Wir lassen uns einfach mal so stehen und halten fest, dass es schon zeitaufwendig ist. Ich würde gerne noch mal auf die, zurückkommen auf die Frage von vorhin. Nennen mal bitte noch kurz, damit man das möglicherweise auch sich selbst mal antun kann, wenn man sich zu dem Thema interessiert. Gerade laufende Dinge, die konstruktiv sind und wo ihr die Finger mit im Spiel habt.
Also was mir sehr persönlich auch sehr wichtig ist, ist, dass der Gesetzentwurf, der gerade fertig wurde, den findet man aktuell bei netzpolitik.org und der ist im Wesentlichen geschrieben von Ulf Böhmeier über die Störerhaftung. Das ist schon lange ein Anliegen des CCC. Wir wollen uns beteiligen, auch über den Sommer, einer ordentlichen Kampagne. Also ich hoffe, dass wir auch Parteien finden, die sich anschließen. Das ist ein fertig formulierter Gesetzentwurf, der aus meiner Sicht innerlich sehr gut ist, der vor allen Dingen aber mit großer juristischer Expertise zur Verfügung gestellt wird. Man muss natürlich Unterstützung finden.
Wir haben einen Gesetzentwurf zur Störerhaftung, wenn du noch die Güte hättest, kurz zu erklären.
Hier geht es um die Frage, was man eigentlich demjenigen androht, der Netzzugang zur Verfügung stellt. Wenn man sich sein Netz bei der Telekom oder bei Vodafone klickt, so haben die gewisse Privilegien. Nämlich, dass sie erstmal für die Inhalte, die darüber gehen, nicht haften. Das gibt es für kleine Provider so nicht. Wenn ich meinen WLAN zu Hause öffne, dann muss ich eventuell mit Strafen rechnen, wenn jemand, der diesen WLAN mitbenutzt, dort irgendwelche rechtlich bedenklichen Dinge tut. Dieses Privileg, was große Provider haben, würden wir gern für kleine Provider auch sehen, weil wir es für ein zukunftsträchtiges Projekt halten.
Weil dann einfach jeder seinen WLAN aufmachen kann und nicht Angst haben muss, dass er verknackt wird, weil irgend ein Spinner meine Little Pony voll im Motor geladen hat.
Die Idee verbindet sich auch mit Ideen von Freifunk und auch mit Initiativen, die diese Rechtssicherheit mal bräuchten. Auch der Entwurf dieses Vorhabens ist schon einige Monate alt. Das heißt, da gibt es auch einen langen Prozess. Das wird nicht so einfach sein wie in Hamburg, bestimmt nicht. Aber ich denke, es lohnt sich. Da müssen wir eben dranbleiben. Bisher gibt es erst mal einen Entwurf, und die Digi gestern hat den veröffentlicht. Aber wir gucken mal, ob wir da einen Mitstreiter finden. Ich würde mich da auch gerne selber engagieren. Ich denke, im Club wird es da eine ganze Menge Leute geben, weil es auch viele Freifunker gibt. Es gibt aber noch mehr. Ich finde es ganz interessant, dass ich in letzter Zeit auch ein bisschen darum bezahlt habe, dass ich ganz gute, konstruktive Sachen mit dem Crowdfunding ergeben habe, also für politische Kampagnen Geld zu sammeln, dass sich eine Zeit lang Leute fulltime darum kümmern können. Das hat in letzter Zeit immer mal ganz gut funktioniert. Und das letzte Beispiel, was wir uns vorher noch mal überlegt haben, ist natürlich die Stiftung Datenschutz. Die haben wir lange gefordert. Und vor zwei, drei Tagen hat sich ergeben, dass die Regierungskoalition jetzt tatsächlich mal einen Vorschlag gemacht hat. Sie hatte den übernommen in ihren Koalitionsvertrag auf Betreiben der FDP. Das ist eine langjährige Forderung. Und jetzt ist erstmal ein Vorschlag da. Der Vorschlag ist ein bisschen unterirdisch, aber zumindest sieht man, dass so langjährige, also steht der Tropfenhöhe den Stein, wollte ich fast sagen. Also man kann versuchen, darüber ein bisschen was zu schaffen. Ist halt alles noch nicht so perfekt. Die Stiftung Datenschutz soll in erster Linie eine Transparenz über Datenschutzgebaren von Unternehmen und Behörden darstellen. Das ist in der jetzigen Idee noch nicht so ganz da. Man vergleitet ganz gern mit einer Stiftung Warentests, wo man eben auch eine gewisse Vergleichbarkeit herstellt und eine Transparenz, wo der Verbraucher sich informieren kann. Und so vergleichbar hatten wir eine Stiftung Datenschutz vorgeschlagen. Das ist tatsächlich Jahrzehnte alt, das Konzept. Das geht auf Spirosymethes zurück. Also, drei Jahrzehnte schon. Wir hoffen eigentlich nur, dass die Nachfolgerregierung das aufgreifen wird. Denn bisher, man kann ja den Vorschlag von einer Koalition jetzt mal nachlesen, finden wir ein bisschen dürftig, weil die beschränken die Idee mehr auf so einen Gütesiegel Datenschutz, was uns glaube ich nicht so sehr weiterbringt. Aber zumindest ist die Idee mal in den Köpfen.
Was wollt ihr? Was ist der Gegenvorschlag der Konstruktive?
Wir wollen eigentlich vor allen Dingen so eine Art von Vergleichbarkeit herstellen, wie wir bei Warentestern kennen. Dass man zum Beispiel zwei, drei Plattformen hat und tatsächlich sinnvoll und einfach vergleichen kann, wie sind denn die Datenschutze gebaren, dass man auch diese langen AGBs, die Datenschutzerklärung, verstehen kann. Aus meiner Sicht muss es eine Kombination aus technischer Perspektive und juristischer sein, sodass man wirklich einfach mit diesem Tool einen mündigen Verbraucher wiederherstellen kann, der selber entscheidet und zwar informiert entscheidet und sich nicht selbst da so durchklicken muss. Es gibt so eine Ansätze auch schon von anderen Organisationen. Die Verbraucherschutzzentralen bieten da teilweise an. Es gibt Plattformen wie Sicher im Netz, wo man sich ein bisschen informieren kann. Wir hätten halt gern, dass der Staat das unterstützt, auch mit Geld. Denn das kostet viel Zeit, das juristisch und technisch alle zu untersuchen. Das ändert sich sehr schnell. Alleine, wenn wir an Facebook denken, ist ja alle paar Monate wieder mal eine Änderung. Und da muss man auch hinterher sein, das sollte aktuell sein. Ich finde, da muss der Staat, wenn er schon keine ordentlichen Gesetze im Bereich Datenschutz macht, da mal hinterher sein, wenigstens die Verbraucher zu informieren, sodass die auch danach entscheiden können. Ich finde das ein wichtiges Anliegen, was übrigens auch, was für alle diese Gesetze gilt, nach Europa getragen werden muss. Denn Deutschland ist gesetzgeberisch nach wie vor ein Vorbild. Und wenn wir das schaffen, bestimmte Dinge durchzusetzen oder auch abzuwehren, ist es natürlich auch immer über Europa und darüber hinaus wichtig.
Okay, dann haben wir also doch die, wie heißt das, Datenschutz. Ich würde jetzt gerne auch nochmal ganz kurz das andere beleuchten wollen, die andere Seite des politischen Aktivismus von Hackern. Und das ist, entschuldigen Sie, Sie haben eine Technologie, die müssen wir mal kaputt machen. Könnt ihr das mal an einem Beispiel in den letzten Jahren erläutern, wie das vonstatten geht? Also weil, um es nochmal zu rekapitulieren jetzt die Sendung, ist es ja so, es gab dieses Positivbeispiel, Leute setzen sich zusammen, arbeiten einen Gesetzesvorschlag aus und dann wird darüber geredet, da kann man auch Kompromisse machen und so. Und dann hat das ein gutes Ende genommen. Bei diesem Wir machen deine Technologie kaputt, gilt es ja, die Politik davon zu überzeugen, dass nicht nur, dass es da irgendwie einen Kompromiss zu finden gibt, sondern man muss die Idee fallen lassen. Also das ist ja das, was da eigentlich erreicht werden soll. Gibt es da ein Beispiel, an dem ihr es illustrieren könnt?
Es gibt natürlich sehr viele jetzt.
Jetzt nur eins.
Ja, eins reicht. Ich meine, viele werden die auch kennen. Also die Netzsperren, etwa auch die Vorzeitenspeicherung. Als Beispiel, wo wir heute schon so viele Hamburger Sachen haben, wäre natürlich der Wahlstift ganz gut. Denn hier war es eher so, dass man sich auch ein bisschen prinzipielle Gedanken gemacht hat. Also ist diese Technik grundsätzlich zu unterstützen? Ja, nein, vielleicht und warum? Und da konnte man am Beispiel Hamburg als Hacker immer mit dem Vorteil arbeiten. Man hat dann irgendwie diese Technik. Man kann sie auch auseinandernehmen, man kann sie im Hacker umsetzen.
Okay, also es gab so einen Wahlstift. Was hat der genau gemacht und wie ist er kaputt gemacht worden?
Dieser Wahlstift in Hamburg war ein kugelschreiberähnliches Gerät mit einer Sensorik in der Stiftspitze. Und die zeichnete auf, wenn man auf dem Papier ein Kreuz machte. Das heißt, man erhoffte sich, dass man eben mit diesem traditionellen Papierwählen sehr ähnlich im Verfahren elektronisch zählen kann, indem man einfach die Sensorik nutzte und ein speziell präpariertes Papier, was man dazu brauchte.
Also ich mache tatsächlich noch mal ein Kreuz, aber das Ergebnis wird elektronisch ausgelesen.
Richtig, das war für Hamburg auch relativ wichtig, denn Hamburg hat kein Wahlzettel, sondern ein Wahlbuch. Das heißt, das ist ein relativ kompliziertes Wahlverfahren.
Das haben wir übrigens mehr Demokratie zu verdanken. Die haben das Personenwahlrecht in Hamburg eingeführt.
Die waren tatsächlich erfolgreich. Und da war es natürlich so, dass wir als Hacker immer den Vorteil haben, wir haben die Technik, wir können uns die ansehen. Und die Schwachstellen entdecken. Und dann kann man natürlich auch sehr viel leichter mit den Medien arbeiten, weil die natürlich diese Skandalisierung mögen. Das ist klar. So ähnlich ist es letztlich mit dem Staatstrojaner im Oktober letzten Jahres auch gelaufen. Man hat dann die Technik, man kann die auseinandernehmen, man kann die Schwachstellen auch benennen, ganz klar. Man kann die Rechtsbrüche anhand der Technik klar machen. So war das natürlich für den Hacker dann auch ein Fest.
Aber wie war es denn bei dem Wahlschiff? Was ist denn da genau? Was habt ihr da nachgewiesen? Und wie ist dann vor allen Dingen die Reaktion auch gewesen?
Zunächst mal gab es da auch mit Hamburg Gespräche. Da war tatsächlich ganz am Anfang, als die Idee aufkam, war schon die Überlegung da, hey, wollen wir mit denen konstruktiv zusammenarbeiten? Also es gab mal so ein Beirat, so einen technischen, wollen wir da reingehen? Aber da war schnell klar, dass wir das deshalb nicht machen können, weil keinerlei Transparenz gegeben war. Das heißt, der ganze Prozess sollte unter der Decke bleiben. Alle Erkenntnisse, die wir da hätten über die Technik gewinnen können, die wären halt so einer sogenannten NDA zum Opfer gefallen. Wir hätten da unterschreiben müssen, dass wir da öffentlich nichts darüber sagen. Das war für uns natürlich, ja, machen wir nicht Kriterium. Das glaube ich für den Club auch bei allen technischen Projekten. Und dann war natürlich so, dass die nächste Jagd war, wir brauchen diese Technik in die Hand. Ist ja auch immer nicht so einfach. Und da war auch übrigens über Informationsfreiheitsgesetz nichts zu erlangen, denn da spielen ja immer Geschäftsgeheimnisse der lieferenden Firmenrolle. Das wäre ja jetzt in Hamburg eventuell ein bisschen anders.
Das wäre jetzt einfacher, ja.
Genau, war aber damals nicht. Das heißt, wir mussten uns erstmal so ein Ding besorgen. War schon nicht so einfach, denn die Firma hat da immer wieder Modifikationen vorgenommen an der Technik auch. Also immer dann, wenn wir da wieder Sicherheitslücken aufgedeckt hatten. Wir hatten auch Informationsveranstaltungen damals. Also wir haben da so eine Strategie gefahren, die teilweise zusammenarbeitet, aber dann letztlich war uns wichtig, wie wir das hacken können. Also einmal über den Rechner, wo diese Wahlstifte dann ja auch eingesteckt werden mussten. Die Technik haben wir uns näher angesehen, aber letztlich haben wir den eigentlichen Hack über Papier gemacht. Und das Papier hatte die Programmierung. Das war nämlich prepariert mit kaum sichtbaren Microdots, also ganz kleine Punkte, die eigentliche Programmierung des Systems darstellen. Und so haben wir dann noch angesetzt, indem wir einfach Papier manipuliert haben, um es um zu programmieren.
Also der Stift hat im Prinzip eine Mini-Kamera und guckt, an welcher Stelle des Papiers ihr das Kreuz macht. Und das lässt sich halt leicht austauschen.
Genau, das haben wir auch getan, indem wir das Papier, das Wahrheitszeitlicht manipuliert haben.
Das sieht aus, als ob ich Partei B wähle, aber in Wirklichkeit das Papier ist von Partei A drunter.
Du machst das Kreuz bei Partei B, aber vorher hat man halt das Feld, wo das Kreuz hinkommt, ausgetauscht gegen das von Partei A.
Das ist nicht wirklich sichtbar, weil die Punkte sind ganz klein.
Also grundlegend kaputt kann man auch relativ leicht manipulieren.
Es gab bei diesem Wahrstoff noch andere Hacks, die wir natürlich überlegt haben. Der simpelste Hack ist natürlich, du sagst, in Hamburg bringt ihr eure eigenen Stifte mit. Dann gibt es ein Problem für die Wahlorganisation.
Oder die lustige Idee, bringt doch einfach einen Edding mit und malt einen kleinen Punkt auf die Linse, wenn ihr morgens die ersten im Wahlwahl seid.
Da waren viele Angriffspunkte, aber letztlich haben wir uns natürlich auch darüber geärgert, dass die Stadt da viel Geld verloren hat. Denn ein Teil der Technik war schon gekauft worden und das Geld war verloren. Das waren über 5 Millionen Euro.
Was ich mir jetzt als die schwierige Stelle vorstelle, ist, man kommt immer an und sagt, wir haben das jetzt gehackt und man will ja eigentlich erreichen, wir benutzen das Teil nicht. Aber was ich mir vorstelle, ist, dass die sagen, das können wir doch reparieren.
Ist auch so, ist bis heute so. Ist es immer noch so? Ja, natürlich auch beim Staatsdrojaner. Bei all diesen Dingen oder bei der Biometrie, wenn man zeigen kann, wie leicht man Trappen bauen kann. Natürlich ist immer die Argumentation, das Problem fixen wir. Das kennen wir, aber wir finden das schon immer heitern, weil das doch immer dieselben Argumentationsmuster sind.
Wobei, also ich glaube, der Wahlstift ist in Hamburg nachhaltig vom Tisch. Also wenn ich das Wort da im Rathaus erwähne, dann werden die alle ganz blass.
Es gab einen juristischen Unangenehm mit Nachspiel. Wir haben über mehrere Instanzen gegen den Hersteller prozessieren müssen. Weil? Ja, der hat uns das Wort verbieten wollen. Das war also ein Meinungsäußerungsdelikt, wie man so schön sagt. Sie wollten also, dass Teile unserer Pressemitteilung zurückgenommen werden und nicht weiter veröffentlicht werden. Da mussten wir über zwei Instanzen gehen. Das ist natürlich für den CCC auch immer ein hoher finanzielles Risiko. Und natürlich auch viel Arbeit. Also, muss man mal sagen, wir sind ja generell bei Gerichten zugange. Beim Verfassungsgericht ist es natürlich so, dass die Arbeit, die man da reinsteckt, ist niemals umsonst. Die hat natürlich eine große Wirkung, aber es gibt ja darunter auch noch Arbeit. Einmal dann, wenn der CCC selbst prozessiert, oder eben weil er vor allen Dingen angezeigt wird, aber auch, wenn man mal als Gutachter tätig ist und auch das kommt vor. Das macht teilweise viel Arbeit, kann aber auch wichtig sein, weil sich dadurch nicht die Gesetzgebung, sondern die Rechtssetzung ändert. Nämlich durch bestimmte Gerichtsverfahren. Also es ist tatsächlich, man hat mit den Juristen öfter zu tun, als man vielleicht sie möchte.
Ist aber auch sozusagen im Prinzip eine Art von Politik, also eine Art von ihr ändert unseren Lebensumraum.
Bei dem Wahlstift war es klar, dass es auch eine Medienkampagne war. Also wir müssen dann mit dem wollen und müssen mit den Medien arbeiten, um das Thema überhaupt in der Bevölkerung interessant zu machen. Dass es also hier Schwächen an den Systemen gibt. Das war aber schon immer eine Strategie des CCC von Anfang an, mit den Medien und der Öffentlichkeit zu arbeiten. Andere Chancen haben wir ja nicht. Nicht wahr? Wir sitzen ja gerade in den Medien.
Sehr schön macht ihr das. Wunderbar.
Also man muss auch mal sehen, so eine Projekte wie in Hamburg oder auch beim Wahlstift oder auch bei der Vorwärtsentsprechung, wo dann ja auch ein Urteil kam, natürlich motiviert das für andere Themen, wo es nicht so gut läuft und wo man dauernd Klatschen kriegt und wo eben andere Mehrheiten im Parlament sind, die einen überstimmen oder eine andere Meinung haben. Das motiviert dann wieder, wenn man mal eine Schlacht gewinnt. Das ist schon wichtig.
Das wollte ich gerade noch fragen. Wir leben ja tatsächlich in einer Demokratie, also zumindest ansatzweise, möglicherweise. Und jetzt habt ihr ja sozusagen so Themenvorschläge. Wir machen konstruktive Gesetzesvorschläge, die werden auch umgesetzt. Es gibt eine Technologie, die ist aber grundsätzlich kaputt, und das können wir euch auch zeigen. Und dann gibt es ja möglicherweise in der Mitte noch so Sachen, wo ihr sagt, es gibt hier ein Thema, und aus politischen Überlegungen sind wir dafür, dass es so und so läuft. Und dann sagt die Mehrheit aber so, nee, wir stimmen das anders ab. Kann man sich dann trotzdem damit zufrieden geben?
Naja, das ist die typische Kompromissfrage. Die hatten wir ja beim Transparenzgesetz ein bisschen abgeschwächter Form auch schon. Natürlich sind es manchmal Kräuten, die wir schlucken. Und es gibt eigentlich oft im CCC eine ganz klare Meinung, wo diese rote Linie ist, also wo kein Kompromiss mehr geht. Oder wo es sich nicht lohnt, weil es grundsätzlich falsch ist. Aber das ist natürlich von Thema zu Thema sehr unterschiedlich. Also ich würde mal sagen, manchmal braucht es auch ein bisschen Zeit, dass man eine Kompromisslinie finden könnte. Also bei Open-Data-Projekten gibt es da manchmal durchaus so eine Fragestellung. Also etwa bei klassischen Fragen wie, was ist denn öffentlicher als Datum und was ist ein privates Datum? Da kann manchmal ein Graubereich sein, da muss man sich auch mal einigen.
Ich habe da ein schönes Beispiel. Zum Beispiel hatten wir ja in dem Gesetz auch die Baugenehmigungen drin. Jetzt hast du aber das Problem, dass nach aktueller Rechtsprechung die Flurstücknummer, also jedes Grundstück in diesem Land hat eine eigene Nummer, die ist aber eigentlich nach Rechtsprechung ein personenbezogenes Datum. Jetzt bringt mir aber, wenn ich jetzt zum Beispiel, ich wohne neben einer riesigen Brachfläche und da soll jetzt neu entwickelt werden, da ist irgendein schwieriger Investor am Start, der macht nur Luxuswohnungen mit Karloft und so weiter. Und ohne die Flurstück-Nummer kann ich ja nie rausfinden, was da passieren wird. Und wenn es da einen Bauantrag gibt und so weiter. Und das sind halt so Sachen, wo dann immer wieder auch drüber nachgedacht wird, wo drüber gerungen wird. Findet man das gut? Eigentlich als Datenschützer findet man das gut, dass das geschützt ist. Andererseits aus sozialer Sicht braucht man das Datum vielleicht. Und daher gibt es da immer wieder Rangeleien und Diskussionen drüber.
Also politische Arbeit auch für Hacker bedeutet irgendwann auch Kompromissbereitschaft?
Naja, aber vielleicht in einem etwas begrenzteren Rahmen.
Aber überhaupt.
Man kann natürlich radikaler auftreten, als das viele Politiker können, weil sie einfach an ihren Parteikonsens gebunden sind.
Das ist klar zu sagen. Aber letztendlich muss man, wenn man politisch arbeiten will. Wir beschäftigen uns gleich noch mit dem, also ich vermute das zumindest als anstrengendsten Aspekt der politischen Arbeit, das ist die Mitarbeit in der sogenannten Enquete-Kommission für Internet und digitale Gesellschaft. Bevor das losgeht, machen wir noch das Fritz-Info mit Nachrichten, Wetter und Verkehr. Eine halbe Stunde haben wir noch hier im Blue Moon of Ritz, heute das Chaos Radio, wo Constanze Kurz und Dodger vom Chaos Computer Club zu Gast sind, beziehungsweise das Studio übernommen haben. Hallo und willkommen zurück.
Wir haben das Studio nicht übernommen.
Na komm, ihr sagt hier schon jetzt zwei Stunden lang, was gerade so geht.
Du hast auch mal was gesagt.
Ja, so ein bisschen. Zum Beispiel darf ich am Anfang einer halben Stunde mal sagen, wir reden heute darüber, wie Hacker Politik machen. Wir hatten schon ein sehr positives Beispiel, nämlich in Hamburg das Transparenzgesetz, wo nicht nur Hacker überlegt haben, wir machen jetzt mal Politik, sondern wo das auch noch geklappt hat und das Gesetz durchgegangen ist.
In schnellster Zeit.
In schnellster Zeit, wo jetzt also der Staat in Zukunft sagen muss, wenn er irgendwelche Entscheidungen trifft, muss er die öffentlich verfügbar machen, so dass man die sich einfach runterladen und maschinell auslesen kann. Wir haben auch schon ein bisschen gesprochen über Projekte, die auch konstruktiv sind, aber nicht so schnell vonstatten gehen und auch darüber, dass der Club der Ansicht ist. Manchmal Dinge auch einfach kaputt machen muss, um zu zeigen, dass bestimmte Technologien nicht gehen. Jetzt gibt es eine Sache, wo auch eine Vertreterin im Club dabei ist, die ich mir persönlich sehr anstrengend vorstelle, von dem, was ich außen davon wahrnehme. Und das ist die Mitarbeit in der sogenannten Enquete-Kommission für Internet und Digitale Gesellschaft. Und da sitzt auch Constanze Kurz mit drin, die im Studio ist. Kannst du noch mal ganz kurz zusammenfassen für Leute, die das noch nie gehört haben, was das eigentlich ist?
Also eine Enquete-Kommission ist im Bundestag eine Art Untersuchungsausschuss und soll den zukünftigen Gesetzgeber beraten. Da hast du dann keine konkreten Gesetze gemacht, sondern man guckt sich an, wie sollten zukünftige Gesetzgeber in den später gefassten Beschlüssen, vielleicht technische Entwicklungen, die sich ergeben, mitbedenken. Man macht Vorschläge, also ist die Idee und das Ergebnis dieser Enquete-Kommission ist im Wesentlichen ein recht langer Bericht. Der Grund dafür ist, dass in diesem Einsetzungsbeschluss, der von den Parteien des Bundeswerks beschlossen wurde, sehr viele Themen drin sind. Das heißt, alles, was mit Netzpolitik und Internet zu tun hat, im allerweitesten Sinne wurde in diese inhaltliche Liste aufgenommen. Und wir werden da also einen sehr umfangreichen Bericht am Ende abgeben.
Wie kommt man denn überhaupt dazu, da mitzuarbeiten? Also wie ist das vonstattengegangen?
Für den Club war es so, dass uns alle Parteien des Bundestages angesprochen haben, als klar war, dass es diese Enquete-Kommission irgendwann geben würde.
Deshalb haben wir gerade vergessen, die besetzte Hälfte Politiker und andere Hälfte Experten, die die Parteien benannt haben.
Es sind 17 Abgeordnete des Bundestages, und zwar paritätisch, also so, wie die Parteien gewählt wurden. Und 17 Sachverständige, die jeweils von der Fraktion benannt werden. Die Abgeordneten haben einen Vertreter noch, also wenn sie mal nicht können, dann haben sie einen Stellvertreter, die die Sachverständigen nicht. Und es gibt den sogenannten 18 Sachverständigen, das ist die Öffentlichkeit. Die sollte sozusagen mitarbeiten. Das hat aber doch insgesamt nicht gut funktioniert für die meisten Projektgruppen. Es gibt ein paar Ausnahmen. Aber zumindest arbeiten wir auch noch daran, die jetzt neu eingesetzten letzten Projektgruppen wieder mehr der Öffentlichkeit zuzuwenden. Es ist nicht so einfach, wie sich das vielleicht viele gewünscht hatten.
Aber nochmal zurück zum Anfang. Da stand fest, diese Kommission soll besetzt werden. Und alle Parteien aachten sich, hey, wir wären bestimmt total cool, wenn jemand beim CCC von uns mitarbeitet.
Wir wissen nicht genau, wie die Parteien im Einzelnen den CCC sehen. Es gab Gespräche, das sind tatsächlich so eine... Also die CDU hatte zum Beispiel Kambinengespräche. Das sind wirklich so Hintergrundgespräche. Man versucht auszuloten, was stellen die sich vor, was stellen wir uns vor und geht die irgendwie zusammen. Tja, und dann haben wir die Gespräche geführt. Es war auch noch nicht klar, wer vom CCC denn machen würde. Wobei natürlich die ganzen Mehrleute vom CCC gesagt haben, nee, auf gar keinen Fall, mach ich nicht.
Warum? Also grundsätzlich, das ist so politikergedönst oder eher, weil das zu viel Arbeit ist?
Ich glaube, weil am Anfang ein bisschen umstritten war, ob das viel Sinn ergibt, ob da wirklich was bei rauskommt. Also es war von Anfang an nicht so ganz klar, was soll das eigentlich.
Also das ist halt nicht ein Gesetzvorschlag, sondern es ist der Vorschlag für eine Richtung, in die ein Gesetzvorschlag mal gehen könnte.
Man macht halt ein bisschen Ausblick in die Zukunft. Man versucht den zukünftigen Gesetzgeber ja auch zu beraten. Und das war nicht allen gegeben. Man glaubt, man muss schon auch ein bisschen... Leidensfähig. Jetzt sagst du jetzt im Nachhinein, mir war auch am Anfang nicht klar, wie viel Arbeit ist das. Was ist das für ein Prozedere? Wie würde Klima dort sein? Das wusste man ja vorher nicht. Das ist richtig. Wie ist das gekommen? Wir haben uns angehört, die Parteien sich vorstellen und versucht unideologisch ranzugehen. Wir hatten damals mit der Linksfraktion überhaupt keine Kontakte. Also wir kannten eigentlich nur einen Abgeordneten näher, mit dem wir mal zu tun hatten, wegen kleinerer parlamentarischer Anfragen, die wir mit mehreren Parteien öfter mal zusammen machen. Aber nachdem wir mit ihnen gesprochen haben, war schnell klar, die wollen was von uns im Sinne von wirklich Gespräch suchen. Die wollen uns nicht beeinflussen. Das heißt, es ist vollkommen klar, dass wir da immer unsere Meinung vertreten können und da auch nicht irgendwie mit denen ins Gehaar gekommen. Dann haben wir das so gemacht. Und ich habe es eigentlich auch nicht bereut, denn die beiden Abgeordneten sind ja bloß zwei mit denjenigen, die ich arbeite. Es sind Halina Wafsiniak und Petra Sitte, das sind übrigens auch zwei Frauen, was ich sehr schön finde, weil diese gesamte Unionsfraktion besteht immer aus Männern und die FDP auch. Und unsere Seite, wo die Linken sitzen, sind die Grünen und die SPD, das ist auch so aufgeteilt. Die sind dann immer so bunt und mehr Frauen als Männer. Das ist lustig. Naja, ich muss sagen, beide Parlamentarier, das ist für mich auch ein Lernprozess gewesen, sind für mich in vieler Hinsicht Vorbilder. Also sind beide sehr bürgernahe Parlamentarier, mit auch richtig Herzblut, mit Politik, aber sie sind natürlich auch als Mitglieder der Linkspartei immer so ein bisschen, ja, die Bubenmänner, mit denen arbeitet niemand gern zusammen. Die Linke ist ja nach wie vor im Bundestag auch relativ weit außen, mit denen reden sie alle nicht so gern, aber sie sind für mich in vieler Hinsicht so richtig Vorbild-Politiker. Ich bin erstaunt gewesen, weil es natürlich verschiedene Typen von Abgeordneten gibt. Für mich ist das ja auch ein interessanter sozialer Einblick in dieses Raumschiff da.
Also auch mit einer Partei zusammengearbeitet, die möglicherweise man vorher gar nicht so viel Schirm hatte bei dem Thema.
Die hatte keine Ausform und die Netzpolitik, das war alle noch ein bisschen im Fluss und ist natürlich auch innerhalb dieser Partei oft umstritten. Es ist ja nicht so, dass sie sich immer alleine sind.
Und du kannst aber letztendlich sagen, bist du da als Vertreterin des Clubs und bist sozusagen der Partei da auch keine Rechenschaft. Aber wie muss man sich das jetzt?
Na ja, man musste das oft anmerken. Und ketten mussten wir uns als Sachverständige, ich hab das auch sehr häufig selbst getan, abgrenzen von den Parteien. Also ich hab immer wieder darauf bestanden, dass sie mich nicht einsortieren in die Linkspartei, sondern dass ich Sachverständige bin. Das betone ich manchmal bis heute. Also das haben nicht viele andere der Sachverständigen gemacht. Und wir haben da Sachverständigen gern immer mit ihrer Fraktion gestimmt. Also wir haben da richtig Stimmenvieh, die einfach nie abweichend gestimmt haben, was mich natürlich bestört. Weil ich mich auf so eine Parteilinie als Sachverständige nie eingelassen hätte.
Jetzt ist es ja so, das klingt alles nach hoher Politik, auch wenn es nicht direkt im Gesetz ist. Kannst du uns mal ganz anschaulich erzählen, wie ist denn, wie funktioniert denn so eine Sitzung? Also was genau machst du denn da? Und vor allen Dingen, wie gehen die Leute in so einem Ding miteinander um?
Also die Arbeit besteht ja einmal aus den Kommissionssitzungen. Da kommen alle zusammen, die teilweise auch von weit an reisen. Da nehmen nicht nur Abgeordnete, sondern auch die Sachverständigen. Aber die wesentliche Arbeit passiert in den sogenannten Projektgruppen. Da sind also thematisch die Themen aufgeteilt. Und dann teilt man auch die Abgeordneten und Sachverständigen auf, je nach ihren Interessen. Dann man ja nicht in der großen Kommissionssammenarbeit, sondern sich dann immer so acht oder zehn oder zwölf Leute aktiv beteiligen an dieser Projektarbeit. Und nach längerem Hickhack war klar, dass diese Projektgruppensitzungen ganz zum großen Teil nicht öffentlich sind. Und dann geht es natürlich auch anders ab als in der Umkehrkommission in der Großen Runde. Denn die ist ja gefilmt, die gibt es als Stream auf Bundestags.de. Und da ist immer viel Scharfwächs da reden und so. Und da ist vor allen Dingen auch sehr viele Geschäftsordnungstricks.
Was ist denn ein Geschäftsordnungstrick?
Das ist zum Beispiel, naja, die Union ist zum Beispiel einmal nicht erschienen. Die Unionsfraktion, die FDP, das ist die Enquete-Kommission war einberufen. Und die sind aber nicht erschienen zum Beginn. Dann haben wir natürlich den stellvertretenden Vorsitzenden, der ja schon zugegen war von der SPD damals, der Herr Dörrmann, der ist mittlerweile nicht mehr dabei. Da haben wir ihm gesagt, na ja, dann machen wir eben unsere Enquete-Kommission so. Aber das sind dann so Tricks, dann kommen die einfach nicht. Oder sie haben Abstimmungen verschoben über Geschäftsordnungstricks. Da war mir vorher nicht klar, dass die so eine Spiele spielen. Ich habe früher wahrscheinlich mal den naiv und doof war. Ich habe das für sachlicher gehalten, aber oft ist es eben, ja, das ist eine rituelle Partei, taktischer Art oft.
Das hat sich bis nach Kindergarten an.
Ja, manchmal ist es wie Kindergarten, also mehrere Sachverständige waren ein paar Mal drauf und dran, da auch zu gehen. Also vor allen Dingen einen Tag, wo sie uns da haben sitzen lassen und einfach nicht kamen.
Also was passiert dann, da kann die Sitzung nicht stattfinden, weil die nur stattfinden kann, wenn so viele Leute da sind?
Man hätte stattfinden können, aber der stellvertretende Vorsitzende hat sie ja nicht eröffnet und der Vorsitzende gehört ja zur CDU und da kamen nicht.
Warum geht man da nicht einfach?
Wir haben uns tatsächlich ein paar Mal überlegt, da gab es ein paar Sachverständige, die das überlegt haben. Aber dann, also letztlich, also zumindest für mich war dann die Überlegung zum einen, also mir waren manche Themen sind mir sehr wichtig. Man nannt da eine Menge darüber, also wer welche Positionen hat. Ich denke, man kann da auch einen Teil der Überzeugungsarbeit leisten. Also teilweise sind die Berichte, die jetzt geschrieben wurden, schon relativ, aus meiner Sicht, ziemlich modern und zukunftsträchtig. Man versucht halt im Konsens zu arbeiten. Wer mich manchmal am Montagsabend nach dem Bundestag trifft, ist ja meistens montags, der merkt dann immer schon mal eine schlechte Laune. Aber es gibt eben auch mal gute Momente, wo man sie zum Beispiel mal überzeugen konnte, wenn man Punkte in die Berichte bekommen hat, von denen man es nicht erwartet hat. Ja, es hat halt so negative Schattenseiten. Im Club wurde teilweise auch belächelt einfach, weil durch diese parteitaktischen Scharmmütze, glaube ich, die Enquete insgesamt jetzt einen schlechten Ruf hat. Aber aus meiner Sicht hat sich trotzdem gelohnt, wenn es viel Arbeit ist.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, ob man das nicht möglich ist als verschwendete Lebenszeit. Also auf der einen Seite hast du Transparenz gesetzt in Hamburg, haben halt was bewegt, ja, und dann hast du diese Kommission, die dann was entscheidet für eine Regierung, die es gar nicht noch gibt und das dann...
Also jetzt im Nachhinein, ich bin noch nicht ganz fertig mit dem Präsumieren, weil die Arbeit läuft ja noch. Also vielleicht würde ich es auch anders sehen, wenn die Enquete-Kommission ihre Arbeit abgestaßen hat. Ich würde es niemandem raten zu tun, muss ich offen sagen. Und ich könnte auch begründen, wieso, aber ich glaube tatsächlich, dass die Wirkung und die Arbeit, also das ist tatsächlich auch viel Schreibarbeit, die da reingeht, auch Zeit, das lohnt sich nicht für den Output. Andererseits ist es mir so wichtig, dass es, wenn sich nicht noch schlimmere Geschäftsordnung, Tricks und Trollereien der Parteien da zugesellen.
Wenn jetzt jemand vom Neuartigen Rundfunk empfangen wird, will ich auch mitmachen, wie fängt man es am besten an?
Für mich gibt es ein paar Grundsätze. Einen davon habe ich von dem von mir sehr verehrten Norm Schomsky. Norm Schomsky ist ein amerikanischer Intellektueller, der eigentlich ein Philosoph ist, der sich Gedanken macht über die Gesellschaft. Und er hat in einem Buch, und er sagte doch oft in Interviews, mal analysiert, warum wir in den westlichen Demokratien, wo wir uns gut beteiligen können, wir haben in den Parteien, in denen wir mitwirken können, wir haben vergleichsweise eine starke demokratische Mitwirkung, wir haben Transparenz, warum gerade in diesen Gesellschaften viele so diese Agonie haben und glauben, sie können nichts ändern und Politik oder Parteien verdrossen sind. Und für mich ist wichtig, dass ich die Möglichkeiten, die ich besitze, nutze. Und die sind so vielfältig, man hält es kaum aus. Man kann sich eindringen in den NGOs, von denen in Deutschland viele gibt, die auch teilweise viele Erfolge verzeichnen können. Man kann sich natürlich in den Parteien selbst bereit machen, wenn man zu diesem Typ Mensch gehört.
Sind das denn tatsächlich, im Umgang mit Politikern, die ihr beide gehabt habt, sind Politiker andere Menschen?
Sag du mal für Hamburg, da ist es ja nochmal anders im Land.
Also ich glaube halt, die Politik verändert die Menschen. Weil in dem Moment, wo du in diesem Spiel bist, musst du dich den Regeln unterwerfen. Du fängst halt dann wahrscheinlich auch irgendwann an, irgendwelche Winkelzüge, Geschäftsordnungstricks und so weiter zu probieren oder auswendig zu lernen, musst dich Regeln unterwerfen, was jemand anders nicht machen würde. Aber gerade in Hamburg habe ich einfach die Erfahrung gemacht, bestes Beispiel war einer der Leute, die auf der SPD-Seite mit uns verhandelt haben, oder zwei von denen, waren nach der Bürgerschaftssitzung, wo das Gesetz beschlossen wurde, mit uns, mit den Bündnissen Bier trinken. Die waren auch auf der Grillparty, die wir eine Woche später gemacht haben, weil die es einfach cool fanden, mit uns das durchgekämpft zu haben. Und das heißt aber, das ist nicht der Archetypus oder der prototypische Politiker, sondern die sind einfach dichter an den Leuten dran. Aber ich glaube, Politik verändert die Leute, klar.
Ich denke, im Bund merkt man das noch mehr. Ich beobachte in den Projektgruppensitzungen oft eine wirklich sachliche, konstruktive Arbeit. Das ist auch oft angenehm oder auch einen gewissen Lärm willen. Für einige der Politiker dort waren viele Themen, gerade wenn es sehr technisch wird, noch unbekannt oder sie wussten wenig darüber. Aber es gibt natürlich da auch Politiker, die da drinsetzen, muss ich ganz offen sagen, die hören nie zu. Die haben sich nie wirklich sinnvoll beteiligt. Das gibt es da auch. Man muss natürlich schon sagen, dass es doch einen Unterschied macht, ob man eher so ein Hinterbänkler ist und sich bestimmten Themen zuwendet, also jetzt nicht so sehr stark in der medialen Öffentlichkeit steht, oder ob man schon eine Menge zu sagen hat in einer Fraktion und ändert. Der Machtfaktor ist nicht zu unterschätzen. Generell gilt für die Landesparlamente, dass es eine angenehmer Atmosphäre ist. Ich habe das ja auch in anderen Landesparlamenten schon erlebt. Im Bund ist es schon ruppiger, natürlich.
Okay, also einsteigen ihr auf Landesebene für Anfänger?
Ich denke, man muss sich sein Pläsier suchen. Und zwar sollte man sich das Pläsier danach suchen, zuerst mal was einen innerlich interessiert. Ich denke, das Wichtigste ist, wenn man wirklich ein bisschen mit der Politik arbeiten will, dass man Kompetenz hat. Denn sich das sachlich anzueignen, ist erstmal schon die beste Grundlage. Dann kommt man viel besser ans Gespräch. Und dann sollte man aus meiner Sicht nur die Wege suchen, die man selber will. Wenn man will, kann man sich ja heute in vielen Parteien engagieren. Neue alte etablierte Jugendorganisationen, lalalala, all das da. Oder eben die NGOs. Natürlich im Club kann man es genauso machen. Man kann sich seine Ecke suchen. Aber wir haben heute auch das Netz. Das heißt, man kann seine eigene Öffentlichkeit schaffen. Also ich glaube, die Möglichkeiten waren nie besser. Und ich glaube, das ist auch der Grund, warum letztlich jetzt so viele neue Sachen kommen, die konstruktiv sind. Ich denke, das ist ein Trend, der sich fortsetzen wird. Es wird mehr davon kommen. Und die Politik kann und wird sich dem nicht mehr verschließen können. Und das ist eine Chance für uns. Wir müssen die ergreifen.
Also was ich ganz kurz für mich persönlich daraus gezogen habe aus der ganzen Nummer ist, ich will keine Parteipolitik machen. Ich mache lieber außerparlamentarisch das Thema, das mich gerade bewegt und das Thema, wo ich sage, da bin ich dick drin und da will ich jetzt was bewegen und mache von Außen Druck.
Das geht mir ganz genauso.
Na weil diese ganzen Parteien-Hierarchien, ich muss mich erst mal da durchkämpfen, ich muss durch die ganzen Instanzen durch, bis mir dann irgendjemand mal zuhört und so weiter. Sobald dieser ganze Parteien-Overhead, der da dranhängt, das ist nichts für mich.
Es ist auch ein gewisser Luxus, den wir haben. Also das betrifft Dodger und mich glaube ich in selber Weise. Also zunächst mal vertreten wir Positionen hinter denen wir originär immer stehen. Also das geht für mich als Club-Sprecherin aber sowieso. Also ich würde nie was vertreten, also dann rede ich halt nicht drüber, wenn ich den Konsens im Club nicht teile. Ich kann einfach wirklich meine sachlich begründete Meinung vertreten und muss mich nicht irgendwelchen Parteiflügen beschlüssen. Das empfinde ich als Luxus, weil diese Unabhängigkeit würde ich mir immer wahren wollen.
Brauchen wir trotzdem Parteiarbeit?
Ja natürlich. Parteien sind...
Also wer das will, bitte machen.
Ja klar. Parteien sind schon... Es wurde immer viel gemeckert über Parteien. Auch schon bevor die Piratenpartei aufkam. Also letztlich erfüllt die eine wichtige Funktion. Deswegen haben wir das Parteiengesetz und deswegen ist es ja auch so grundgesetzlich festgelegt. Sie sind nur aus meiner Sicht in manchen ihren Funktionalitäten total verharzt und irgendwie festgefahren. Aber auch das ändert sich gerade. Also ich finde da ist auch viel im Fluss.
Die sollen sogar twittern jetzt manche von denen.
Hast du das schon mal gesehen?
Na, in so einer Kamera dabei, Bundestag.de, da kann man das manchmal sehen.
Heißt das Olive-Kahn ist Politiker? Naja, egal. Noch eine ganz persönliche Frage an beide von euch. Was ist das nächste Projekt, das ihr angehen wollt?
Dodger? Das fängt an.
Oh ja, ich habe da ein total gutes, ich war morgen früh auf Diffusion.
Komm, wir dürfen Werbung für Diffusion machen, oder? Aber ist das ein politisches Projekt eigentlich?
Man kann ja eh keine Werbung dafür machen, weil es ja eh immer ausverkocht ist.
Ne, ich muss gestehen, wir haben ja jetzt in Hamburg noch ein bisschen was damit zu tun, dieses Informationsregister zu konzipieren und umzusetzen, weil das haben wir gar nicht erwähnt. Das dauert noch zwei Jahre. Die Zeit haben sie dafür. Und wir haben uns in den Verhandlungen explizit ausgebeten und reinschreiben lassen, dass wir die beraten dürfen bei der Umsetzung des Ganzen, damit das nicht hinterher so ein Multimillionen-Dollar-Grab wird.
Also Umsetzung heißt jetzt nicht mehr das Gesetz, sozusagen.
Wir programmieren nicht die Webseite dafür für dieses Informationsregister.
Aber ihr habt ein Auge drauf.
Wir haben ein Auge drauf, was sie da treiben und wie das dann später gemacht wird. Und das wird uns noch mindestens anderthalb bis zwei Jahre beschäftigen. Ja, ich hab zu tun.
Gibt es denn sonst noch ein Thema, wo du vorschlagen würdest? Da sollte man sich mal drum kümmern.
Na ja gut, wo immer Leute gebraucht werden, sind natürlich alle aktuellen Themen.
Na genau, und da dein Lieblingsthema.
Ja, im Moment treibt mich Leistungsschutzrecht ziemlich um. Also das macht mich so ein bisschen rasend.
Okay, ich überlege gerade, kriegen wir es jetzt kurz zusammengefasst? Nein, ich möchte dann an dieser Stelle die Gelegenheit für Werbung für mich machen. Bei Trackback haben wir in den letzten beiden Sendungen versucht, zu klären, was das Leistungsschutzrecht ist und womöglich keine gute Idee ist, dass man es im Internet nicht mehr verlinken darf.
Ich würde das ja anders zusammenfassen.
Bitte?
Na ja, der Punkt ist doch, wenn sie diesen Gesetzentwurf durchbringen, haben wir ja schon gewonnen. Und wenn sie ihn aufgeben müssen, haben wir auch gewonnen.
Könntest du bitte so eine Diskussion nicht sechs vor zwölf anfangen?
Entschuldigung, aber ich finde, da können wir nur gewinnen, oder? Das ist doch super.
Das können wir vielleicht an anderer Stelle noch mal genauer ausdiskutieren. Was ist dein Projekt, dein nächstes?
Also die, die wir jetzt aufgezählt haben, werden mich natürlich, klar, ich habe traditionell immer relativ viele Projekte, aber derzeit, also für die Sommerkampagne, finde ich es sehr attraktiv, diesen Gesetzentwurf zur Störerhaftung mit einzelnen Parteien zu besprechen und euch der Kampagne zu bauen. Mal gucken, ich denke, das wird ein Clubprojekt hoffentlich noch werden. Also bisher ist es ja erst mal nur der Entwurf, der bei Netzpolitik Org zu finden ist, aber ich hoffe, dass man auch eine Kampagne daraus bauen kann. Aber die Themen wie die Vorurtszeitenspeicherung, ja oder also Akta natürlich, aber auch die Kulturwelt mag als Langpassprojekt werden und auch mich weiter beschäftigen. Also ich habe traditionell viele Baustellen, ich muss mal Dodger mal Recht geben, Leistungsschutzrecht wird in den nächsten Monaten auf jeden Fall auch ein Thema sein.
Naja, möglicherweise in einem Monat an dieser Stelle gibt es hier ein Chaosradio geben, mal gucken, worüber wir dann reden.
Das ist nicht ungewöhnlich, wenn man sagt, du hättest eben wieder das Leistungsschutzgeld vornehmen.
Recht, nicht Geld.
Denk nochmal nach, Dodger.
Leistungsschutzgeld. Na gut, das vielleicht beim nächsten Mal. Hier geht es erstmal, das war's mit dem Chaosradio. Vielen Dank, Dodger. Vielen Dank, Constanze. Für das Vorbeikommen und Erklären und Teilhaben lassen wir vor allen Dingen auch am Persönlichen erleben, wie Politik geht, wenn man sie auf einmal selber macht. Hier kommt jetzt Henrik Schröder mit dem Night Flight. Er wird euch Punk-Musik in die Ohren hineingeben. Und ich habe nur noch eine Nachricht für dich. Mein Name ist Markus Richter. Macht immer schon eure Back-ups und lasst euch nicht überwachen.